[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king football
morning in america columnist contributor
to nbc sports if i would have told you a
month ago tom brady was retiring what
would you said pete
i'm surprised
because i didn't see this until the drum
beat started i didn't see it coming i
thought he was going to keep playing
i think he has managed to uh
basically bifurcate his two lives
and he's done it very very well
but i do think dan it was me
in i think when tom brady was 34 maybe
33 who
he told i want to play till i'm 45.
and uh i remember it very very clearly
because i
walked away from him that day
thinking uh
i think he's crazy
i just don't think and really part of
his legacy
is that he's made it possible in a game
where the conditions for quarterbacks
are monumentally easier than they were
two generations ago
uh he's also made it very possible for
people to think i can play
until i'm in my mid-40s because you're
just not getting beaten up you just have
to dedicate your whole life to doing it
how you eat how you drink what you don't
drink what you don't eat
and and how you train
um
but i do think
it's easy to say something at 34
and then at 44 your life is different
did you ever think
that you would say you know what i'm
going to turn down this contract from
espn to be the biggest person
in the worldwide leader of sports i'm
not going to do this anymore you're
ready
you know eight years earlier that dan
patrick would have said are you out of
your mind
and so you just life changes
and his life has changed and there's one
other thing dan
don't you also think
that at some point
not that you get tired of doing this but
you say really what more can i do
seven super bowls great i just had one
of my greatest years at age 44 could i
do this yes do i want to do this i'm not
so sure anymore yeah and the standard is
so high that the bottom line is winning
super bowls and you know for tom it's
either super bowl or bust
whereas other people in all walks of
life you know we don't have that hey if
i don't win a sports emmy uh or i've won
enough then i can retire tom always
wanted to be about winning super bowls i
was also curious with you being a hall
of fame voter how many hall of fame
careers does tom brady have
i saw that his career was separated into
three
seven year
windows
and that you know he could have made the
hall of fame for
any or all of those seven year windows
i don't know i think clearly
uh
you could have cut his career in half
yeah and both of those careers would
have been hall of fame careers because
one would have had three
super bowl titles and the other one
would have had four
and you know so obviously i think both
of those he could have made it
but
it's a fun exercise but it's not really
reality
i talked to a former tv exec last night
and i said
what would tom brady
what what would it cost to bring him in
as an analyst
amazon if they want to bring him in on
thursday night and i don't know if brady
wants to do this but
um
can you see brady
having anything to do with the game when
he's you know now that he's done could
he be an analyst in your opinion or what
do you want to be
i mean personally
i have no idea what he's going to do
have not talked to him nothing since
this announcement
it would surprise me if he would want to
do that dan and the biggest reason is
that
you know it's like i had a conversation
with sean payton last week about this
sean payton really
wants to put his you know dip his toe
into the tv waters
and i said you know the best ones
kind of piss people off
you know sometimes that you know they're
not afraid to say anything and he goes
oh i know i know
and and look i'm not saying brady could
do whatever he wanted to do
if he put his mind to it
but does tom brady want to go on tv and
say what a dumb throw by matthew
stafford or or
i and i don't there's different ways to
be critical of people too
but i think
tom brady wants to be excellent
at whatever he does and he's proving
that with sort of his forays into like
religion of sport with gotham chopra uh
and and to some of these clothing stuff
that he's getting into now he wants to
be big time he wants to be the best
to devote yourself to be good at tv
i know that everybody is going to listen
to that and think oh that's a pile of
crap
ask
football players who go into tv
about how hard tv is not just how hard
being on tv
how hard it is to be great being on tv
because there aren't many of those
that's jason whitton how about brady and
gronk
doing their version of the manning cast
if the mannings by the broncos or part
of the ownership there now i got my
brady cast with with him and gronk
problem
it would probably be hilarious but i
have a feeling there would be more
drinking
on that uh on that cast i'm all in
i'm here oh yeah yeah i'm always more
drinking than there is on the manning
cast although i'm not sure what there is
in those tumblers that they're using on
the manning cast
he's peter king his column football
morning in america joining us on the
program uh let's get to brian flores
with he had his opening statements teams
have responded
elway responded the giants responded
steven ross responded
what's next
well did you ever think that john elway
the new york giants or stephen ross
would say yep he's right we did all
those things
of course they're going to deny it and
maybe they're all correct i i we don't
know we don't know anything
i think what's next is going to be a
long period of
a uh the lawyers for brian florey's
trying to get more
um black coaching minority coaching
candidates involved in this suit because
it would just strengthen their case
but you know as mike florio points out
we were on tv a couple of times this
week dan
um
as he points out the nfl is going to do
everything humanly possible to make sure
that this
case
will stay
as it is mandated in brian florey's
coaching contract with the miami
dolphins and that says
that if you have any uh
uh
any any uh dispute
with a team with management with anybody
it is going to be adjudicated
uh in arbitration
and roger goodell is the ultimate
arbiter and can either appoint who's
going to hear the case or whatever so
the nfl does not like airing its dirty
laundry ask the people of st louis they
wanted their pound of flesh and instead
got 790 million dollars but you know
their own the nfl owners never had to
appear in court to address
you know the uh the complaints that st
louis had
and so i think the nfl will try
every way that is possible
to make sure that this never
uh that nobody ever has to be uh
you know nobody ever has to appear in
court
um or that bill belichick doesn't have
to go under the hot lights of a
deposition
and so i think that is what is next sort
of jousting to see what the venue for
this is
well the commissioner does his state of
the union address at the super bowl
is he going to still do that do you
think and does he take questions
i'm sure he'll do it and i believe he
will take questions
and he'll get answer he'll get asked a
lot of questions about the flurry suit
about the washington football team and
the renewed charges against dan snyder
it still
absolutely boggles my mind that
you know as one of the attorneys in the
case said yesterday
why is it that there's a 200-page report
on some
possibly possibly deflated footballs and
there's zero page report on uh the
washington football team and it's a
great great question
um so he's going to get questions on all
that stuff assuming and i'm assuming i
mean he answered questions last year i'm
assuming he's going to answer questions
this year
and i wonder does the commissioner ask
for steven ross's cell phone
um
i i mean obviously he should or or you
know he should listen
roger goodell needs to
uh
for the good of the game
and
for the good of the integrity of the
game
he needs to investigate this absolutely
thoroughly and the way you do this
is with an independent investigator
um that's how you investigate the
stephen ross story because any other way
if it's headed by jeff pasch
you know
you're never you're never gonna really
feel good about the results of it so in
my opinion i think
that that has to be that's the only way
that roger goodell can uh answer
questions
you know with
impunity
about what actually what did really
happen in miami i just saw this jim
harbaugh has told the detroit free press
mitch album he is done chasing nfl
jobs i mean we'll see what happens tom
brady said i'm playing till i'm 45.
i mean we'll see what happens dan
um when you say you're done chasing nfl
jobs
you know what if
mark murphy and the green bay packers
come to him in two years and say we'll
give you x y and z to come coach our
team
was he chasing that job no and look i
don't really know jim harbaugh so i
can't tell you
what that is but dan when a guy returns
after a national signing day
uh spending a day with an nfl team
and then when he comes back to his other
team and he says hey i'm back everybody
what what is everybody supposed to be
who was supposed to believe that he'll
never look at another nfl job i doubt it
i mean you know and for him to tell
anybody that i'm done chasing it well
maybe he is that doesn't mean
the real statement will be
i will never coach in the nfl again
that's the real statement all right i'm
i'm not going to be a candidate for any
more nfl jobs you know write it in stone
and otherwise
that really doesn't mean very much to me
if the mvp vote was taken after the
super bowl
the whole season
who would win
well you got to tell me you wins the
super bowl let's see
if the bengals win would joe burrow be
the mvp
if you if you base it on the entire
season i vote for joe burrow yeah i mean
my final three was aaron rodgers who i
voted for tom brady and joe burrow okay
and
obviously if you include the playoffs
i'd vote burro because
how in the world can the cincinnati
bengals this 54 year old franchise
you know that everybody thought at the
beginning of the year was in the bottom
10
everybody thought at the beginning of
the year was in the bottom 10 and then
they win the super bowl with joe burrow
playing lights out in many of those
games it's got to be borough
how important is winning the super bowl
for la to establish a fan base
i think it would really help them
having said that dan i was at the nfc
championship game
and i thought what happened there was
really good for football
honestly i'm sure that there were some
rams executives who were doing the
rodney dangerfield oh what's going on
here and there and they're unhappy with
it
but
that place
was as loud a football stadium for both
sides it was a weird weird crowd
because the decibel level was at 105
when the 49ers had the ball and it was
at 105 or 110 when the rams had the ball
it was fantastic it was almost like a
european soccer crowd in some ways it
just never stopped
the whole day i thought it was great and
look
everybody has said that all the rams and
the charges they need to establish their
own fan base
i guess that that's true but really
what's wrong with 20 000 fans of pika
team the green bay packers or the the
chicago bears or or whoever
coming in and playing and coming into
your stadium and providing a loud uh
antidote or or whatever to the other
side there's nothing wrong in that with
that we've we've got it in our heads
that that's faulty that that's wrong but
why is it why can't there be fans from
both teams
wouldn't you know if if you're the
minnesota vikings
and you've got a game in la against the
rams or chargers in december
i mean why wouldn't you want
all of the fans you know 20 000 people
from minneapolis st paul and the whole
area to come in isn't that good for
business isn't it good for the economy
in l.a
pete great stuff as always and uh safe
travels to la thanks for joining us
thanks so much dan take care peter king
football morning in america columnist